in my head I smoked a caviar cone which
is a joint that has hash oil in it I
smoked seven joints this morning no
maybe four maybe five what we just
smoked a small joint and another mom
smoked two blunts oh great
are you guys down for roll-ups
guys Terry's gushers dipping dunking
swooshing cheese and cracker version of
dungarees I knew it's gonna be Gus's man
class different gesture where they all
stick together in the plastic kind
tastes like plastic plastic hmm it
tastes like glue it's everywhere now I
mean guys shaking I could die a happy
man oh I can't I live my dream I smoked
a blunt through Snoop Dogg before that
was my first part where I'll be cool
dying no this surge oh man the coolest
drink ever invented don't use that oily
taste in your mouth yeah this is like
it's Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle boy hmm
and it's so fun I love when a candy can
figure out a way to make eating it an
event
it's like surge Oh grody that one's not
great well give someone spill the
strawberry daiquiri on sand
hey mom would you grab me a fun dip at
the cherry YUM diddly dip flavor chili
dip like you know you've got me the razz
apple magic dip me Mom can't you really
I think you have to to pretty much stop
everything else to consume this candy
chassé just like cheese melted popsicle
mm-hmm yep that's what this is it tastes
disgusting I don't think it's good maybe
blue raspberry this kind of tastes like
grape it doesn't even taste like blue
blue that's the favor push pop oh my a
bro are you kidding me this is way too
involved
I'm glad as a belt clip though it's not
just about taste it's also about play
another interactive indeed it's not
about how it tastes it's how it makes
you feel I feel like an adult baby I'd
say that a good thing about snacks from
the 90s were that you could play with
them also eat them please to CAF gushers
likes not so much goes into the toys and
snack it was more about color the flavor
you know what I'm saying my favorite
flavor was red
Gus is Gus's it gets so gushy that
effect like a marshmallow get so mushy
matter of fact what is umami of this
reminds me of everything I used to eat
in the night because how about you Wilma
Sam